not going to lie it was slightly
committed to break down my old karate e
to do this one so I was going to do a
video talking about all the trailers
they came out at the Super Bowl and I
might still depending on how quickly I
can throw that together there it's
probably already irrelevant but what
happened more recently and what I'm
going to talk about first first full
trailer for iron fist came out well
we've had sort of teasers up to this
point this was much more let's lay out
some plot kind of thing and and I think
that's worth talking about now I don't
know how excited I am for iron fist
aside from the fact that I have enjoyed
to some degree or another all of the
Marvel Netflix shows up to this point I
emphasis not a character i'm
particularly invested in i think i've
only read one iron fist story and that
was because it was the one that was the
debut of Sabretooth who the character I
really like so I don't know a heck of a
lot about the guy I don't know a lot
about his history at least not having
actually read the stories I mean I know
I know where he fits in the Marvel
Universe that's kind of it though and
the trailer it was fine it was pretty
good and left me oddly cold not because
anything was bad or wrong with it I
think I think what it was is the one
thing that I really want out of this
series wasn't really in the trailer on
because we think I really want I want
come to movie style ballet almost you
know highly choreographed mom take
action scenes now that's not say there
haven't been good action scenes in the
Netflix shows you know daredevil has had
some brutally awesome action scenes but
that's you know that's a very rough and
tumble down and dirty style fighting
which I do enjoy but what I want out of
this one is I want you know sort of the
crouching tiger hidden dragon so the
matrix yeah I want that kind of fight I
want something that is so choreographed
and they move so fast of just one wall
and I didn't really get that from this
trailer that's not to say that it won't
be in the film it's just that the way
the mood and the pacing of the trailer
to rapid cut to be able to show off that
kind of stuff if it is in fact present
and being that that is the major thing
I'm hoping for from the series to have
it not be there kind of it means the
trailer didn't really give me what i was
asked her in terms of what it did give
me um nothing wrong with it the whole
setup is a lot of people are going to go
boys this is a lot like Batman Begins
and think that's a comparison was kind
of unavoidable because yeah Danny R and
as a young ish white guy who owns a
company and left for a while to train
and there's now fighting crime on the
street I think Batman comparisons are
going to be kind of inevitable I think
the only thing that kind of made me
going yeah is the little glimpse we get
a Madame child because I think at this
point the the netflix marvel shows have
done a pretty good job of building up
sort of the mystery and the intimidation
of this little asian lady and I'm I'm
intriguing to see where they go with
that also we got a few glimpses of
Claire rosario Dawson who has been great
in every shipment she's great in
everything I've never seen her be bad in
anything you know if the thing she is in
overall is bad she is never bad in
anything that i see i think the effects
that they've got going with the fist
looks pretty good i I'm hoping that they
kind of neo go with the idea that he has
to build up that energy to use it so
that you know it's not like every punch
as an iron fist punch but he needs you
know to be able to get in prepare and
and that's that's the look in the
feeling like that so overall it's fine I
can't say that it gets me pumped but it
didn't give me any reason to sort of
dampen my hopes and enthusiasm for the
show either so I suppose it did its job
it reminded me that this is coming and
I'm still coming yeah I want to see that
so it did well off I suppose so I'll
leave it at that did you see the trailer
for iron fist what were your thoughts on
of whatever they were drop something
down in the comments let's talk about it
don't forget to Like subscribe hit that
little bell so you get notifications on
when I put new stuff up called me on
twitter at council of geese check out
the council of these podcast available
on iTunes and stitcher
and until next time this council is
adjourned